things that stuck out in this news
conference down there a question about
North Korea and the trip by the CIA
directors Secretary of State nominee
Mike Pompeo uh saying that it was a good
trip and that the conditions are set for
his meeting the president's meeting with
Kim jong-un also saying that they are
working on getting the three Americans
that North Korea is holding to be
released and there are there is progress
also that there will be bilateral trade
talks and negotiations in free fair and
reciprocal trade deal with Japan and
then finally asked about the Muller
probe and whether he was going to fire
Muller a Rosenstein Stein rather the
president saying they've been saying
these two gentlemen for three for five
months that I was going to get rid of
them they're still here I want this over
essentially I've got negotiating to do
let's bring back our panel Jonathan Swan
Abie Stoddard and Molly Hemingway
Jonathan what stood out to you a couple
of things it's clear that Japan is going
to try and reduce the trade deficit by
buying lots and lots of American weapons
that seems to be their strategy to
reduce the trade deficit which is the
major metric that Trump is concerned
about on that area it's also clear that
Japan is quite concerned about the u.s.
giving too much for too little
you saw our BAE after the president
spoke say we need to keep up the maximum
pressure campaign on North Korea we
can't give up an inch they need to
actually do concrete things to
denuclearize so you do see some of that
coming through it's clearly a very close
relationship there the two have a close
personal rapport and you know trade is
one of the big issues that Trump's this
tweet earlier this is just a picture
from them golfing earlier today and that
was referenced in the in the news
conference as well they do have a close
relationship Shinzo Abe a was the first
leader to reach out to President Trump
after he won the election Molly your
thoughts on what you heard yeah it
wasn't arresting that he talked about
the emotional issues in play and how
much it meant to him that Donald Trump
talked about the abducted people and and
the need to get them back how much they
agree on issues like the
ducted Japanese also that they are of
the shared mindset about maximum
pressure against North Korea North Korea
has previously said that they are going
to denuclearize previous administrations
have gotten them to say that but it
doesn't actually happen so that's why
it's very important and I think Abba
twas very good about talking about this
the need to verify any denuclearization
plans and that they are unified at
Mattapan I want to play the sound buddy
I talked to Shinzo Abe a in Japan
something very similar that he mentioned
in this news conference he mentioned to
me take a listen
north Korea has used those talks just to
gain time to further develop the nuclear
program as well as missiles so North
Korean dialogue just for the purpose of
dialogue is meaningless that is our
experience yeah and he emphasized that a
B I think that's that's still their
concern but that they're somewhat
hopeful according to this news
conference today right Prime Minister
Abba is very you mentioned he was the
first to dart across the seas to meet
with president-elect Donald Trump during
the transition because he was so afraid
of the kinds of things that President
Trump said as a candidate about the the
the expense of these alliances that we
have and questioning their usefulness
and he because he's Japanese and because
he's a good politician wasn't gonna say
anything except for the exact Trump
talking points about fair reciprocal
trade and everything else and
everything's hunky-dory in this press
conference but it's true at what Molly
mentioned he wanted to get out there
that in in public that he's anxious that
the US could get to the table and then
get ripped off and that's why in private
it's clear president Trump made clear
several times he's such a tough
negotiator because in private he's
telling her exactly what he told you
that you could get suckered and that's
my president Trump seemed to say for the
first time I'm gonna walk away if it's
not going well but I was really it was
remarkable to see him thank the Chinese
and also just after that campaign and
this first year for him to strike such a
solicitous tone about the importance of
alliances and to be so emphatic about
his loyalty to Japan it was it was
really a change it was interesting to
watch the atmospherics also the
translators switching for Japan a couple
of
we had a male and a female don't know
why they went to the bullpen but we'll
figure that out and also a lovely
tribute to Barbara Bush at the beginning
with a couple of chuckles where he
praised their 73 years of marriage to HW
Bush saying I'll never beat that record